joe rogan
a canceled culture critic called that by
carlos mancia for canceling him
the rap uh news it is ironic that a guy
who is now saying you shouldn't cancel
anybody at least started
the building of this podcast by
canceling me comedian carlos mancia says
in 2007 rogan stepped on the comedy
store stage to confront carlos mancillo
about
allegations of the latter stealing jokes
from other comedians and from the club
audience
brian redman rogan's friend and eventual
podcast co-host filmed the incident
initially rogan suffered according to
the new york times
the comedy store banned rogan from the
club and the comedian's agency dropped
him however according to the article
rogan and has posted
the clips online and had edited them
together with the footage of mencia
performing jokes alongside with other
comedians telling similar versions of
the jokes the video went viral
ruining mancia's career and reputation
more and more
with each click i had mencia on i
interviewed and we sat down and i told
him i said why don't you go out there
and go
put a tweet out and say do you think i
should go on joe rogan joe rogan why
don't we do it
the interview was done i think a year
and a half ago two years ago maybe
never happened hasn't happened till
today and he keeps going back to the
same place
you both are in this world this is your
space what do you say about what carlos
is saying i'm going to go to you first
okay well you know my opinion because we
had a conversation right so
listen first of all let's let's discuss
what
canceled culture is cancel culture is
not
calling out somebody for deplorable
behavior
cancel culture is trying to bully
society
into a belief system cancel culture is
can't
it's actually this actually this thing
called cultural hegemony
it comes from the frankfurt school it's
it's antonio gramsci
there's a real thing that cancel culture
is and it's try it
the idea is to destabilize any sort of
opposition
to marxist ideas so that's what the
quote
cancel culture is it's cultural hegemony
all right having an opinion on somebody
doing something awful
is not cancel culture so one ned furnace
who
uh is carlos mencia's real name is
trying to use this term cancel culture
which is a legitimately
in my opinion evil political tool it's a
manipulation tool
it's gas lighting it's it's cultural
bullying
all right it's a witch hunt that is here
to shut up
opposition to political ideals that's
what canceled culture is
being called out for stealing ari
shaffer and bobby lee's material
when you are the biggest act in the
world by somebody who
who doesn't have the clout that you have
is balls
joe rogan had balls what joe rogan did
is he put his entire career on the line
people may not know this now joe rogan
was on a down swing in his career
they had tried to transfer uh they tried
to transfer him into a movie star
and he bombed he didn't make the
transition from tv to the movies
he bombed ufc hadn't started yet and his
he hadn't
reinvented himself as this you know he
was doing fear factor he was doing news
radio and he wasn't
yeah after after news radio he did fear
factor he hated fear factor so he left
fear factor wanted to do movies the
movies bombed
he's going early at the comedy store
i've played the comedy store if
people don't know it it's the mecca of
comedy it's unbelievable
playing any rooms there it's just such
an awesome thing to be a part of it so
it's like getting in that bad at yankee
stadium right
carlos mancia closed the place out every
night he was the biggest act in the
world
he's the guy comedy central gave the
chappelle show to
right okay they he so what imagine
a nobody comic all right i'm trying to
think of something that would make sense
today
for people that don't know what happened
it would be like i don't know
like um it would be like andy dick
almost
walking on stage to dave chappelle and
calling out dave chappelle for stealing
other people's material
because the other people were like what
am i supposed to do he's dave chappelle
nobody's going to believe me
and that's what mencia did because not
only did mencia steal the material
but then he had the people whose
material he was stealing
fired he had them taken off the stage at
the store so it wasn't enough that he
took their act
he then killed their career this dude is
like it's about as evil as you could be
in the comedy industry
now his whole point is well people did
this for years people people always did
this robin williams stole jokes
right but we didn't have the we didn't
have the material on tape
we didn't have the material on tape this
is something that white comics were
accused of stealing black comic stuff
for years they were accused of stealing
like red fox richard pryor would talk
about it
and uh um who just died uh paul mooney
would talk about this all the time at
caroline's you'd say
this joke is xyz there's there is
parallel thinking which is a real thing
there's only so many jokes there's only
so many premises
all right and how you put those two
things together is yours your material
is yours and there's a lot of crossover
in comedy there's only seven stories
this man was stealing people's stuff
this is no different than this guy
coming in this is our work
my material is my work it's your
currency it's your words or your
currency
if you had an auto dealership and then
the biggest auto dealership in the world
came and just took your cars and you're
just supposed to be like i don't know
what am i supposed to do no you have to
you have to be like bro
what rogan did was valiant it was not
cancel culture
and the fact that he's he he is still
this many years later trying to equate
those two things
tells you exactly who this person is of
course he's going to use the word cancer
culture because that's you know the word
right now but basically he got exposed
he got exposed yeah exposed is the word
that happened absolutely you were doing
something wrong
and someone said had the balls like you
said to be like i don't know about all
this
because you saw what happened to rogan
his agency fired up yeah he got kicked
off gigs he wasn't doing anything more
and then he put the clips out there and
people were like you know what rogan was
actually right here
he exposed him it's not any different
than like what ed edward snowden did for
the nsa and he exposed what the hell was
going on
yeah so you know you you run the
uh the run the risk of getting
literally like rogan could have got
canceled he was cancelled by his agency
exactly he was cancelled the ironic part
is that he exposed
ned or carlos however you want to call
him and
the market took over and said no we're
actually with joe rogan on this this
actually goes back to what pat said
earlier about
how bad ideas that's exactly by the way
kai greene is watching a podcast he just
joined us
kai i got a simple question for you man
are you competing in 2021
mr olympia and if you missed some of the
ideas i had a few minutes ago and you
watch this uh
rerun of the podcast go to hour 25 hour
23 and watch it for a few minutes by the
way
if you can call him now we'll get him on
if he wants to call you we'll dial him
in wow but but i just texted carlos
mencia
okay and just now i just right there i
just texted carlos mancia so
if if you're watching this if you're
watching this
carlos i want to bring you back and
let's sit down on the podcast
and let's talk about this it's been a
couple years here's
here's what i'm a big fan of and this
there's opportunities in
life because to me if you were to name a
country the greatest country in the
world for redemption what would you say
is the greatest usa
baby greatest country in the world this
is the comeback
and by the way is it fair to say that
all of us
need that are grateful the fact that
there is this concept of redemption in
this great country
everybody at this everyday everybody
okay so i'm all for redemption but the
part that
is frustrating is not capitalizing on
the opportunities you have
to redeem yourself and you keep being
authentic
you keep digging so folks if you're
watching this if you'd like to see
carlos come on i've interviewed carlos
menchie on the valuetainment channel if
you haven't found if you go type in
valuetainment
and david and mencia you'll see the
interview it's pretty entertaining to
watch probably one of my favorite
interviews
uh you'll see a lot of there but
if you'd like to see carlos join us on
the podcast not interview
send them a tweet hashtag pbtb david and
i'll uh let's
let's if other people want to see that
we'll invite them if this is something
that you would be interested to see
carlos come here
tell us on twitter if not totally get it
but if you do go on twitter and let us
know
for if you want to see me any young
comics that are watching if there are
any young comics or anybody
wanting to be a comic okay this is
something lenny marcus told me lenny
marcus if you don't know who he is very
very very very funny funny funny comic
he's a 25-year vet he's a curmudgeon
uh name dropping i was at uh stand-up
new york doing a show with him and todd
barry who's got a stadium tournament one
of the funniest dudes of all time and
they both said the same thing cost 25
bucks
copyright your jokes because one of the
bigger things that happens one of the
biggest i'm actually gonna ask you that
if that's even possible copyright your
jokes and one of the biggest thing that
happens is
isn't what carlos has been said carlos
mencia the biggest thing with carlos
mencia is that
he it wasn't that he stole the jokes
it's that he tried to ruin these guys
career
instead of being like bro i'll give you
a writing credit and i'll elevate you
look what do you need you need 500 bucks
here's 500 bucks all right and a writing
credit
i need this joke all right i'm rich now
rich people aren't funny
i don't connect with the common man
anymore rich people aren't funny all
right
here's the deal this is what you got
elon musk is pretty funny no
they they are fine seinfeld is going to
have a bone to pick with you they're
home
they're very funny i'm just saying that
that's the that's the idea the idea
that comics have especially when they've
come from the streets is that once i
make it that's right no longer yeah
that's why jimmy fox
always has like some leaky faucet in his
house yeah something that like the every
man he's like i don't want my house to
be perfect well ellen i want some
weird [ __ ] smoke detector exactly
ellen's last special she addressed it
and it was perfect she was like they
said you're a billion you're a
billionaire you're a billionaire with a
daytime show you can't
you can't uh identify with the common
person anymore and i told my butler that
was ridiculous
like it was a great line you know just
through my pbd always has a broken tv in
his house he keeps a big crack in the
middle of his tv
but the bigger thing than what carlos
mancia did it's a huge huge problem in
new york
is advertising agencies will go to a
comedy show and there'll be these people
who work in marketing and they'll be
copywriters
and they'll see a joke and be like wow
that's going to be great on state farm
and they will just completely steal a
bit and it'll wind up in a commercial
by the way so if you enjoyed this little
short segment from the podcast that we
did here's another short segment to
watch
or if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
[Music]